ces images ont été dévoilées cette nuit
par une société d'imagerie satellite
américaine
on y voit un interminable convoi russe
en file indienne des camions des blindés
par centaines se regrouper approche du
nord de kiev
selon les informations américaines
le convoi s'étendrait sur près de 60 km
entre la ville de primes irsc et
l'aéroport antonoff
au sixième jour de l'opération russe
chacun sait dans la capitale ukrainienne
que la bataille de kiev approche dans
les rues des barricades sont dressées
aux entrées de la ville des panneaux
publicitaires préviennent les soldats
russes
ne devient pas un meurtrier va t'en
reste un humain peut-on lire ici
un peu plus loin un habitant expliquent
comment fabriquer des cocktails molotov
pardus de moteur et 2 par décence
malgré l'imposant dispositif russe ces
hommes qui ne sont pas des soldats de
métier se disent sûrs de leur force
nous accueillerons les russes avec des
cocktails molotov et des balles dans la
tête c'est ainsi que nous les
accueillerons il n'était pas autorisé à
venir ici je ne sais pas qu'il comptait
sauver ici
face à l'avancée russe beaucoup de ces
ukrainiens disent ne pas avoir d'autre
choix que de résister comme ce jeune
homme qui creuse en pleine nuit une
tranchée devant son immeuble
je dois la faire
je n'ai pas de casque je n'ai pas
d'équipement je me voilà en train de
creuser une tranchée au lieu de
simplement étudie et de vivre
normalement
personne ne sait encore quand aura lieu
exactement l'offensive russe
ce midi le président ukrainien a indiqué
que la défense de kiev était la priorité
pour le pays